la malédiction des pharaons c'est le
cours de français du jour les élèves
sont sages comme des images mais
méfiance certains ont déjà goûté au
punition c'était temp Prim j'ai d copier
50 fois aussi je me B pas dans dans le
couloir de l'école et j'ai un atisement
de
conduite céit une grosse punition ça oui
alors tu as recommencé après
oui des lignes à copier a priori rien
d'exceptionnel et pourtant c'est
interdit c'est la circulaire numéro
2000-105 du 11 juillet 2000 qui le
dit les lignes et les zéros doivent être
proscrits autre
précision punitions infligées doivent
respecter la personne de l'élève et sa
dignité sont proscrit en conséquence
toutes les formes de violence physique
ou verbal l'éducation nationale veut
responsabiliser de la légende enignant
il faut qu'il mesure la portée de ces
actes il faut qu'il apprenne ce que être
responsable veut dire on quels sont
alors les moyens des enseignants pour se
faire respecter les punitions
pédagogiques comme un texte à étudier
par
exemplez un élève qui marche du
chewinggum donc ça intervent dans le
règlement voilà donc on va donner donc
moi j'ai des une réserve de petits texte
donc un texte en rapport avec le
chewing-gum et donc la dernière fois que
l'élève a marcher chewinggom je lui ai
donneré ce texte après je l'ai plus V de
chewingom le travail comme punition cela
fait bond dire certains psychiatres pour
enfants
le travail l'apprentissage scolaire
c'est une récompense ça ne doit pas être
une punition et à ceux qui prônent le
coup de règle sur les doigts la réponse
est simple quand les gens disent
qu'effectivement ils ont été battus et
que ça ne les a pas traumatisé euh ils
savent pas ce qu'ils auraient été s'il
n'avaient pas été battu entre les textes
et la réalité il y a encore de grands
écarts et les enfants malheureusement
pour eux n'ont pas fini de copier des
liges